mac and cheese Dyke and cheese baby yes
pack and cheese ok shanira mecha cheese
today I'm gonna be guessing
mac and cheese toppings my friend
Shannon has to guess what these flavors
are and I will be blindfolded we didn't
want to mess up do you see anything oh
you better be very descriptive this is
new technology hard
it literally is half a fork and half a
spoon I forgot that this part is gonna
make me look like an idiot
mmm crunchy smoky is it more salty mmm
Innotech is it state it is cheddar and
ham mac and cheese bacon
oh my ire for the mac and cheese
[Music]
we go a-hole okay this is gonna be a
challenge first why are they comes my
backyard fun
you put it on food on the 4th of July
bananas what are you eating on the 4th
of July
so there's onion oh yeah there's a meat
okay so there's a protein it's a brown
sauce maybe it's a little reddish
barbecue sauce our protein is gonna be
cluck cluck cluck chicken yes you have
to try this you're gonna pass away oh my
god is it on my finger big fan of this
that's bad onions baby I literally had
it for a second yeah mac and cheese yes
that's one you know that thing that
grows in the ground vegetables
uh-huh and the thing that's like purple
or white onion this isn't garnish this
is something that makes you fancier
rosemary Oh bell pepper no bay leaves oh
my goodness this point I'll be friends
oh he eats probably is like frozen pizza
no omega threes baby salmon close is it
my favorite it is your favorite avocado
yeah pico de gallo
I can choose as a foundation for all
kinds of wonderful creations good job
[Music]
ramble back I want to try each one again
[Music]